So, we have
a Di Oreo segment to watch, okay?
Apparently, now that Chud's not
streaming, Nick feels a bit more
comfortable speaking openly about how
upset he's been, how personally deeply
hurt he's been by Chud saying there's
nothing to cover unless you're dick
riding Ethan Klein. Nicholas Di Oreo,
I'm talking to you.
Chud saying that about how deeply hurt
and scarred that has left Nicholas Di
Oreo for like last [__] year.
So, now that Chud's away,
Di Oreo finally feels comfortable
speaking about this.
Um
So, so let's see. Let's see what he's
got to say. Let's see what he's saying.
I'm being like a rapist. My favorite
This is a new form for me. But I will
not have
people like [__] Bow Blax and Tipster
get spoken about for year for like a
year.
Now, this part you could argue it's
about the chatters who are coming in one
guy and him saying it's a nothing
burger. You can do that.
>> And then it's nothing to see here for
this.
And it's nothing to see here for this.
Now, I've not looked at this yet, but
I've got a feeling
that the sweepers are going to be in on
this one, okay?
And I'm not [__]
>> I mean, this is just a dog whistle. We
got like stormed for 2 weeks. This was
like the immediate trend setter.
>> [__] suffering that gladly. That Bow
Blax There's no way he thinks that the
reason he got prodded with the sweeping
[__] so much is just because Chud said
it. There is no way.
There is literally no way.
Dude, it's the the
group the like sort of side of things
that was most lit up over the Tom stuff
was the KF people.
It was the KF people. It was very very
clearly
that sort of side of things, the KF
sector
Kino Casino
end of things. It's It was that sort of
chatter community member
that was like most hit up over it.
I thought most people,
you know, that I saw at least sorry, I
should be clear.
The people that
Nick's talking about when he's saying
Chad sent people after or Chad was like
setting the trend, we're not actually
that hit up over this stuff.
It was not a bunch of spicy chatters
going into Augie's stream chat telling
him he's sweeping during the It was It
was not. I don't say that they they felt
like that. They immediately assumed
that. That was just not the case, like
It just was not the case. They were $5.
I appreciate that. Thank you. Thank you.
It just It just was not the case, but
that's obviously who he's thinking about
here.
They were They were the KFN stuff. And I
don't think Chad has that much influence
over like, you know, what the KFK Casino
sector type, you know, more
that end of things, how they feel about
this sort of [__]
And they've hated Nick and Koi for years
for all sorts of different dramas,
right?
Because they're like, you know, they
were Nick [__] around and made like
videos on
Bloodsport guys and all this [__]
Which is worth talking about for a year,
but Turkey Tom's embarrassing
revelations
are a [__] nothingburger.
Okay?
That is [__] absurd, dude. That is
obvious insane obviously [__] insane,
bro. By the way, it's totally normal if
the entire allegation was just Turkey
Tom sexting for me not to cover it.
That's actually like a normal thing to
not cover when your friend friend gets
exposed for embarrassing details. The
part that makes me have to cover it is
the fact that like a person that I'm
working with is being implicated in like
sex crimes. That's the only reason I
ever covered it on my channel. And if
you're saying that you're too biased to
sit there and laugh at your friend while
they're like leaking degenerate sexting
messages, that's totally fine because I
absolutely would be way too biased to do
that, Uh and I never would. Hate.
Unless there's like an additional piece
of information there that makes me want
to cover it.
>> The day of the diaper is here.
>> it lets you define like what is
embarrassing, right? What's just
embarrassing. When there's like plenty
of stuff that like I would like if
Turkey Tom was
into age play for instance, like that's
something where I think that's just
embarrassing. If Turkey Tom's into age
play, if
if he's into age play, I think that's
just embarrassing. I think that's just
like, you know, kind of a shameful
thing.
Nick thinks that's like bridge burner
material though. And because Nick has
all these bizarre [__] YouTuber
standards that are like, "Oh, well, if
you have this fetish that you engage in
with adults, then I can't be friends
with you." He almost can play this sort
of like amorphous game where it's like
something is simultaneously embarrassing
uh it's like uh it's No, not
simultaneous. It's like it's like
Schrödinger's almost. Like it's a
Schrödinger's like condemnation. It's
like it can both be embarrassing or a
condemnation at the same time, and you
never have to decide which one it is,
right?
It's like
but there was pressure put on him here,
so he had to make a call about whether
he was going to determine these to be to
be, you know, really worth covering,
right? Because ultimately he could have
said that Here's something he could have
said.
Oh, I had a quick look into off stream.
The only thing that substantiated is
stuff that's kind of embarrassing for
Tom,
uh so I don't really want to go over it.
He could have said that. He could have
said that. Cuz that that's technically
true. The only stuff that was
substantiated really was was stuff that
was like kind of embarrassing. The more
serious allegations were not.
Um
so he could have made that call, but he
could he couldn't cuz there was there
was pressure on him.
And I think honestly, you know,
obviously I wouldn't stake a claim on
this, but I think really if I if in my
heart of hearts, I do think
that Nick probably would have tried to
sweep or go up the easy side step the
story maybe if there wasn't this
pressure. If there Now, obviously you
can't know because it's a
counterfactual, so I would never say
straight stake a strong claim on that. I
would never make that a strong criticism
of Nick. Um
But, based on how like the Kai [__]
went, you know,
I would just assume like back in the day
with the Kai cheating with Lulix and
Lulix getting iced out and all this sort
of stuff, I would just sort of
feel like, you know, that's kind of
where where my sense lies. That's where
my sense for things lies is that they
would have tried to kind of avoid it.
Can't prove it. Would never be able to
prove it. Um not even that big of a
deal, to be honest. It's like like I
said, it's counterfactual criticism. Who
gives a [__] Yeah, I do That is
genuinely If you really push my buttons,
that's how I feel.
Yeah, dude.
>> [laughter]
>> Basically, I woke up in the middle of
the night cuz I fell asleep early.
And it was just as this stuff was
dropping. If this is nothing to worry
about, nothing to be concerned about,
okay? Why is the podcast going on
hiatus? So, I put the podcast on hiatus
when it was very clear that I was
streaming the entire time and didn't
have an opportunity to even look into
the allegations. Like, I was live during
this entire time slot.
So, [laughter]
there's no way I could have sat and read
through like what was it, like 50 pages
of Kiwi Farms, whatever the [__] that
happened in that first night. And then
Chud's like, "This tells you all you
need to know." I mean,
Yeah, cuz people are suggesting it's a
nothing burger, as in not worth
covering. It was obviously worth
covering.
There were serious allegations in there.
There was some um what would you call
it?
Contemporaneous evidence. There was like
some slight backing to like at least the
idea they had relationships or something
like that. There's enough there to
cover. There's enough there that is
relevant to cover. So, the idea it's a
nothing burger
is absurd. And you can look to show that
it's not a nothing burger, you can look
to the way his friends have responded.
That makes total sense.
That makes total sense. Whether the
allegations turn out to be true or not,
that statement makes sense. It actually
has no bearing on the truth of the
allegations or whether, you know, you've
looked into the evidence.
It's just there is enough of an
allegation there to where it's not a
nothingburger.
Cool. And it was just as this stuff was
dropping. If this is nothing to worry
about, nothing to be concerned about,
okay? Why is the podcast going on
hiatus, okay? Now, listen, I will be
fair. I know what people in chat are
thinking and they're going to say, okay?
But my concern Dude, I will be fair. It
goes on for like the least [__]
charitable take I've ever heard in my
entire life.
>> Now, ladies and gentlemen, is the big
sweep might be on. Literally 8:00 a.m.
the next morning, the big sweep is on,
guys. The big sweep.
>> But my concern, ladies and gentlemen, is
the big sweep might be on. What?
Okay.
You know, it's it's like autistic, but
he actually does hedge there, doesn't
he? He says, "My concern is might be."
He actually doesn't outright say that
sweeping. He actually does not
outright accuse of sweeping. He says,
"My concern is that it might be on."
Okay? The mid the big sweep might be on,
okay? I am not participating in the big
sweep, okay? This is a totally
legitimate story to cover and talk
about. And that's the end of it, bro.
And if anyone disagrees, if anyone
thinks I'm dis-
>> So again, no statement on the truth of
the allegations. It's clear what he's
saying there. It's clear what he's
saying. Do we need to wind that back a
little bit? The big sweep is the big
sweep might be on, okay? The mid the big
sweep might be on, okay? I am not
participating in the big sweep, okay?
This is a totally legitimate story to
cover and talk about. It's a legitimate
story to cover and talk about. And
that's the end of it, bro. And if anyone
disagrees, if anyone thinks I'm doing He
did say Mike So,
what's So,
that is not a statement in any way on
the truth of the allegations. He's not
saying, "Oh, because Nick canceled Half
Baked, you know Tom's guilty."
or anything like that. He's saying it's
a legitimate story to cover and talk
about. It is substantive and relevant
enough to where it should and can be
covered.
as any other drama. a cop, bro. doing
something wrong, we'll talk about it,
okay? Happy to talk about it. But, there
is little
>> this. I love this. I'm going to
implicate that you're sweeping
>> look And then And then he follows it
with, "And if you think I'm doing
anything wrong, I'm happy to talk about
it." Obviously responding to the idea
that it's a nothing burger that
shouldn't be covered, right? That's like
the point is Tom made here So,
people are suggesting it's a nothing
burger, shouldn't be covered. And he's
also saying it as like the Kai thing,
where people put like a a total lockdown
on, you know, Aiden's even said I think
he was he was told to to ban people from
chat. Don't address it if people bring
up the Kai thing.
back in the day.
That's obviously what is going into
this. That is obviously what is going
into this.
Uh yeah, so I'm going to like brief you
in the ass on this one. And if you want
to come on my stream, I can actually
profit off of you, too. It's like super
cool. It's like such a cool thing that
he does. Hey, I'm going to come in and
I'm going to go [__] you in the ass, and
then I'm going to give you the courtesy
of letting you come on my show. So,
again, Nick just either refusing to
listen to the clip or just being
completely [__] and not
understanding what's being said. Chud's
point that was not
"If you disagree that the big sweep
might be on,
come on my stream." He was saying, "If
you think I'm doing something wrong by
covering this.
Challenge me on that. That's what you're
saying. If you've got a criticism for
me,
challenge me on that.
Wow, truly nothing wrong with speaking
about this and talking about this. And
again, he reiterates, there's nothing
wrong with speaking and talking about
this. He is responding to the idea. So,
he said, the big sweep might be on and
is reaffirming that it's a legitimate
story to cover and talk about.
So, what's the problem here? What's the
problem here?
This is completely legitimate. Now, I
think Chud made firmer statements about
the big sweep in another place on the
stream, I think.
If I remember correctly.
I think they're firmer statements. But
in this clip Nick's showing, this is
[__]
And obviously, if Turkey Tom makes
videos using Kiwi Farms as a source,
okay? Is totally legitimate, of
obviously.
>> I added this part in just for
transparency. I don't think it I don't
think anybody was saying that you can't
cover it because Tom uses Kiwi Farms and
you you know how you know how you can or
whatever. I don't think that's really
relevant to this. Okay.
No one was making that argument. But
obviously Chud is sort of like
responding to the sense that you can't
cover it because of the Kai stuff.
That's obviously what is being sort of
like constantly called back to here.
Right? I've got We're all we're all are
aware of that, right? Everyone that's
been around for more than like a year
must be aware of this.
The the Kai stuff, the Kai cheating
drama between Larx and Tom, obviously
very funny, very big deal, very
hilarious for everyone who knew about
it, was locked down. It was like there
was that one clip of Larx being
confronted about it by Salvo on a
Michael Alberto stream. And like it was
sent to everyone's chats, didn't talk
about it, never mentioned it, even
though it's like hilarious drama that
was already leaking, that it super
embarrassing for the people involved.
And they like ice Liam out and don't
explain the public and all this stuff.
Everyone knows. Everyone can remember.
It's been around for long enough and
it's obviously what Charles is
constantly referring back to.
So, I mean
to make comments about it. It's hard to
be British. True.
>> No question, bro. Okay?
Now Now, he gets back into it here.
>> I don't think Listen, guys. Okay?
Listen, okay?
I do not believe that people have got an
obligation to cover anything. People can
cover what they want, okay? So, this
might be a firmer statement on the sweep
thing. Cuz so far all he's said is it's
legitimate for him to cover it. Now,
this is about whether people have an
obligation to cover it.
>> Could be. What would the coverage be
like if this is about iDubbbz? If it was
revealed that Anisa iDubbbz that that
Anisa was into age play and [__] like
that, what would the coverage
>> I would anchor down and I would slander
them. I would slander the [__] out of
them. I would operate off of zero
information.
>> is obviously not the point that's being
made, is it? It's obviously not the
point that's being made. Also, yes, 100%
Anisa Jomha and my friend of 7 years are
completely interchangeable. You could
sub them in one for one without
affecting that at all whatsoever. But
yeah, I mean he would do that cuz he
does do that. crazy take. I'm actually
partial to my friend of 7 years. And I'm
like openly telling you this. And it's
like totally fine. I streamed about this
last night. And after watching Nick's
stream, I'm kind of [__] black pilled
on the stream.
>> win What's the win condition there?
Wow, you're biased towards your friend.
It's like, well, I now I know why you
don't have any friends from WHEN YOU
STARTED.
>> [laughter]
>> BRIDGE BAY. AND I THINK I DUDE, the cope
laugh at legit just made my [__] skin
crawl, dude.
You don't have any internet friends.
>> [laughter]
>> Jesus, man. He's like mad as hell. He is
mad as
[__] dude. I with no friends is
surprised that people are biased towards
their friends.
And I think the answer to that
>> Shivers down my spine, bro.
And I think the answer to that tells you
everything that you need to know,
doesn't it? And here's the reality.
Yeah,
if if there's no one on the internet
who's able to
be friends with people who they disagree
with and have criticisms for, then
why would you have friends online?
Having friends is
a drama commentator to make your worst
commentator then, surely.
But that's obviously not the case, you
know, there are plenty of people who can
take criticism and have disagreements.
That's why, you know, despite
Chud saying crazy [__] about me and me
saying crazy [__] about Chud
and having criticisms with each other,
I'm still cool with Chud. I'm still cool
with Jay Stokey. Jay Stokey is still
cool with Chud. Chud Stokey, you know,
There are a bunch of people that are
actually cool and disagree with each
other a bunch and argue.
Just not the gay little clubhouse.
Just not this this gay little clubhouse.
>> [laughter]
>> But to me dwindling clubhouse. decides
to talk about this and who doesn't.
This is 100% This this claim right now
is 100% about me. And that'll give you
an indication
of what the deal is, okay? That's going
to tell you everything you need to know.
All right, I'm taking a look at your
channel right now and it appears it's
it's past 8:00 a.m. Not really seeing
your video here. Are you seeing a stream
or a video for Mr. Chud Logic final
stream before I'm away?
the big 26. Our country is in shambles.
Thank you for the $5, money night. Thank
you. Huge appreciate. That was actually
a great time to remind you guys, 520
people watching right now.
Uh 116 likes on the stream. So that's
400 or so people and please move the
cursor to thumbs up and click it or
pressing a thumbs up on the mobile
device, that'd be huge appreciate. If
you want to take support one step
further, you can donate directly through
Streamlabs link in the pinned chat
message.
You can also buy a membership to the
channel, gift a membership to the
channel, gift a whole bunch of
memberships around me through the chat.
Buy super chat which will highlight a
message or read out the TTS or buy super
sticker.
Which is a YouTube image you get for
being a higher chat subscriber to you.
You can go to discord.gg/scrayman,
twitter.com/scrayman, or
reddit.com/r/scrayman.
Thank you. Thank you.
Seems like he ran. Here's the thing.
Now, this is a couple of days later.
In between, he posted this tweet. And
this tweet is the exact same verbatim
argument from the clip. Only now, it's
an all-encompassing [clears throat]
tweet. Right? Why? Only 21k views after
12 hours. It looks like my humble video
going over the first part of the Turkey
Tom allegations is the most viewed on
the topic, which is seemingly a product
of no large commentary channels picking
up the story yet. I have never believed
that people have an Okay, this is the
part that's literally out of the thing
where he's talking about me. Uh I have
never believed that people have an
obligation to cover a story. People can
talk about what they want. That being
said, it seems insane to me that if
Hasan or iDubbz had this exact same
thing happen to them, we would already
have 20 videos from the Daily Slop
channels. So, he's adapting the take to
cover more things. And then, he gets So,
I mean, I obviously agree that it was
about Nick and and Chud totally pussied
out.
Chud pussied out because he realized
that Nick was uh
getting super sensitive about him and
was going to go [__] you know,
cry about it
to [__] Augie and all these people.
Pretty pretty sure that's what happened
is he knew Nick was like behind the
scenes crying like [__] crazy.
Yeah, he doesn't want to deal with
you know, Augie or whoever else
yeah, being uh being turned against him
in addition.
I think that's pretty clearly what was
going on.
to do a call with Augie and he's like, I
have no idea what you're talking about,
bro. I wasn't calling you guys out.
Augie, final stream before I'm away. I
think he eventually concedes to this to
be clear. Play. Hmm, seems like he ran.
Here's the thing. When you were called
us out for sweeping, this was like
>> wait, hold on, hold on. 6 hours before
the allegation.
>> you say us, okay, because people are
very much
>> Nick. Okay. [laughter]
That's because you guys are very
sensitive about getting called sweepers,
okay? That's true. That's absolutely
true. This is complete cope. That is
absolutely true. That is absolutely
true. I'm talking broadly, all right?
And you're looking at it and it's like a
Rorschach test. I'm saying no big
commentary channels pick this up, and
you're sat there going, "He's talking
about me and only me." And it's like,
No, that's just such cope. That's just
such
cope.
>> That's just such cope. Okay, can we go
over the tweet?
>> There might have been 20% Yeah, yeah,
I'm pulling up your tweet right now. Go
over the tweet. Dude, you all said There
might have been like 20% Yeah, yeah, I'm
pulling it up right now. There might
have been like 20% where you were
talking about like a Cheeto or guys
nobody gives a [__] about, but it's
clearly when you're calling out
sweepers.
>> People historically call out me and Nick
for sweeping for our friends. It's been
a thing
that's happened.
You're so sensitive to it, bro. You're
so sensitive to it, bro.
That is true. So, he Absolutely correct
from Charles that they are super
sensitive to it. Now, the issue is he's
saying it while kind of pushing out of
of committing to the to the call out.
Uh so, kind of under cuts a little bit,
but absolutely true, you know, they get
neurotic about it.
It just ain't that deep. It ain't that
deep. But, Nick takes
criticisms
especially on the lines uh lines the
lines of his rep credibility and respect
very seriously. He takes that
very much to heart, you know? It's
clearly hurt him deeply
that all the other commentary RFC types
have like totally turned on him.
The fact that your Alex Gakmos and
Critical Shoguns are not riding Nick's
[__] on Twitter
every day anymore, that clearly really
upsets him.
That sort of thing, because that was his
thing. He He feels like he built that.
You know, he gave some of that to Chud.
He lent that to Chud.
So, the fact he's lost respect there and
those people sort of diss him, that does
get to him. And you hear the way he
talks about
I have left the whole commentary
community behind. I left the whole thing
behind. I left it behind. It's like, so.
And I've been there. You're so sensitive
to getting called a sweeper. You wanted
You were first to I said it in the
stream. I said it in the stream. I said
in the next stream I had spoken to both
of you and you were both Mike talking
about it.
>> Wait, next stream? Oh, the one about the
first stream? What happened in the first
stream? You're just sensitive to getting
called a sweeper. That tweet came about
cuz I looked on YouTube and no multi
100,000 sub channel had spoken about it.
>> had come out like 3 hours. Yeah, but you
kind of already Nick, would you have
respected it more if you just came out
and said, "Yeah, I was talking about you
and Augie, but I was trolling." He's not
trolling. This is exactly This is
actually how he feels. 100%. Chud Logic
is like a terminally raped person who
can barely even hold 1,000 concurrent
viewers. Listen, the seething Well, was
this last week? A month ago? Oh,
suddenly now, all of a sudden, he's
terminally terminally raped person.
Terminally raped person.
>> [laughter]
>> The seething comes out, man. The
seething built up.
Just absolutely bottled up for so long
because he said
Nicholas Diouriou, I'm talking to you.
About some Ethan Klein dick riding [__]
A year of seething just It's like
terminally raped person. You only hate
because of his chat.
Dude. And half his stream seething that
the chat wants him to cover the Ethan
Klein drama, that he's too [__] big
to cover himself. So, he can cover 80
hours of the newest transvestigation on
somebody's hairline. This guy can't even
make decent content now and he's holding
it against me personally.
>> paid him $3.
>> of multi-thousand.
Thank you.
Took your shot at me before that. You
took your shot at 8:00 a.m. the next
morning on me. Go and you
EHD was definitely exhausting for a
year, but this bridge burning is
baffling.
So, you go live in the morning and you
were the problem is that Chud Logic had
an issue with the content that I was
covering over the course of a calendar
year, but he's probably too much of a
[__] to say anything. Not because he
wanted to stay friends with me, but
because he's worried that the shared
audience that I lent him would leave.
That's probably the God's honest truth
of the matter. For the first That's
probably the issue. The The issue is
that Nick D'Orio doesn't want to talk to
people. Nick D'Orio doesn't want to come
on to my stream after I slandered him to
give me free content. Nick D'Orio
doesn't do this, but the reality is he
probably has wanted to Yeah, let you
What even is that point, Chud this? Like
comments about him. Chud this
[__] like digs at him. What does he
mean? Yeah, audience not even revoked. I
lent you my audience, dude.
Yes, he is saying he is saying that you
end friendships
over slight criticism. He is saying
that. He doesn't want to end the
friendship with you
over some digs. He would rather hash it
out with you. Like this is This is how,
you know, Chud and and
I think most people have sort of like um
I don't know, man.
I thought this is how most
guys, in my experience, handle things.
Is if they disagree,
they argue about it,
and then they move on.
And Chud was kind of itching to argue
about it and move on.
And Nick was not allowing that to
happen.
And Nick has clearly bottled up the
resentment he's had from Chud's attempts
to argue about it and move on. And now
this is Nick's opportunity to do the the
ultimate avoidance. The ultimate
avoidance. While he's on holiday,
have a [__] fit on stream,
torch the bridge, be moved on by the
time he comes back, and you basically
never have to talk about it. You never
have to feel the heat of any conflict
because he's too sensitive to have Chud
going after him for a few days. It's
like it is the most transparent,
avoidant, feminine behavior imaginable.
call me out for a really long time, and
he's worried about the community
overlap.
So, that's my stance on Chud Logic.
Oh, just answer the question. If two
women directly accuse Hasan of sexual
misconduct, would Nick cover it before
he responded? What do you think?
Nicholas De Orio streamed about this
last night, and after watching Nick's
stream, I'm kind of [__] black-pilled
on this [__] Who do you recommend for
politics now?
>> about oversaturation of EHD content, but
he milked pirate software until he
couldn't. No, he he has his own topics
that he milks or whatever. But, the the
problem is Wow, it's almost like the
criticism wasn't about whether you cover
a topic a lot.
That if you watch any Ethan Klein
segment that he's doing, it's obvious
that he [__] hates it. He absolutely
[__] hates that he has to cover it,
but there was nothing else to cover that
day, and he resents people who do. I
really like you. Why? Would you? But,
why is he So, I just I don't think
that's the case. I don't think that's
the case at all, but sure.
>> so mad at you. I think I personally,
again, I can never prove this, but I
think he just blames me for it. Because
it's been like my channel's been doing
fine, and I think that he's just like a
petty [__]
Who? Yes or no? So, literally literally
like no one's criticism, aside from like
a few old Nick viewers, literally like
nobody is criticizing Nick for covering
Ethan too much.
That's not anybody's criticism. That
wasn't Chud's criticism when he took
shots at Nick. That is like a few old
Nick viewers who stopped watching Nick
will say he covers Ethan too much, so I
stopped watching him.
No content creator is saying, "Nick
covers Ethan too much. That's the
problem with Nick." That's not a serious
criticism anyone's making. It's about
the things you say in your coverage. And
yes, he knows that, but he's being
dishonest.
He replies to WillyMac by saying,
"Remember when you accused Queen Man and
Augie of doxxing with no evidence
because your feelings got hurt?" And
Willy says, "Crazy cuz I never did that.
I said I was doxxed by Queen Man's
unhinged viewers." And then I criticized
Queen
Awk- awkward moment this video, isn't
it, Nick? Awkward moment that video.
Skipping past that one.
>> Let's hop ahead here.
Augie RFC, "My broom is the strongest
broom many have said." Augie RFC then
tweets out, "My broom is the strongest
broom many have said." And then posts,
"I've been around way long enough to
know that 90% of E allegations are total
[__] Scoring a [__] is they're
trying to do as much damage as they can
cuz they are angry, emotional, and in
some cases evil. Watching people figure
this lesson out for the 50th time as if
it's the first time this has ever
happened has been ridiculously funny to
watch." Keffals appreciated the
shout-out.
Shed was always a [__] stirrer. The
leading and baiting questions he says
always reminded me of Edwin.
Yeah, dude. I Listen, it's Hey, I'm
going to sit here and make as many
comments as possible, call you
sensitive, demand you come on my stream,
then I get a free hour of me screaming,
"You're raped, bro. You're raped, bro.
Debate over."
Wow, dude. So that's so cool.
>> Nicholas the [laughter] goat. I did How
do you get your feelings hurt this bad?
From a from what? From arguing on
stream?
From the suggestion of arguing on
And you're this anal and touchy about
it?
It's crazy, bro.
Thank you for the five dollars.
>> Wow, I get to give you a free hour of
content? That's awesome, man.
Did anybody watch that Augie debate? It
was completely like it was impossible to
watch.
It's almost like you should hear both
sides out and make a decision once the
cards have been played, instead of
jumping in instantly like everyone
wanted me to do. In conclusion, I was
right to wait. You were all wrong, and
Thank you for the Shed. It's sad that he
is clearly sniping at
Well, I'm sure he will now. [__]
[__] all of you. Loco Sore tweets out a
screenshot See, look, he knows Dude, you
literally you could always feel the like
heart, man. You could literally Dude,
it's so transparent. This guy is
literally the most readable [__]
loser alive. It's like so crazy how he
how he has like an audience that buy
into his [__] like our self-mythos.
It's so transparent. He will now He will
now
Yeah, you literally you are so
sensitive. You're dreading him going
live and got and talking crazy about how
you're an Ethan Klein dick rider of
pulling up a bunch of clips of pulling
up the zog stuff whatever laugh just
ripping into you. That you literally
like sensitive about it. You get caught
up about it, and you probably
rationalize it. All right, this is the
saddest part, I think. This is the
saddest part. And Augie kind of does
this, too. Augie was doing this on the
stream the other night.
Rationalize it by saying, "Oh, it's a
career move. I have to maintain this
this respect to keep making money." And
really, you go on Chud's stream, he
screams you're a rapist five times. How
many viewers do you lose off that? None.
You don't lose viewers. It doesn't
impact your [__] opportunities or
anything.
It's just this cope they come up with to
make it seem like um there's more
consequences to losing a debate than
kind of like looking bad.
You know, I can't I can't think of
anyone that's lost their audience off a
bad debate.
Chud uploaded Turkey Tom's video and
captions it by saying, "No [__] way
Turkey Tom's response to the allegations
is showing a bunch of messages where you
can see the main two girls against him
are literally begging for him. Low tier
god and Miskif wish they could do some
[__] like this." And Nick Romancer
replies, "Honestly, the most
entertaining drama video I've watched."
And Loco Sore says, "It's funny because
there You think Tommy C and Nick have
the same personality types? Very
similar, very similar. drama videos with
less care and thought put into them than
this. And this is still one of the
funniest just because the comeback was
what other topics are in here? Accusers
react. I Oh, I want to see some of this.
Yeah, cuz we didn't cover all of it.
>> He is watching the video about the first
30 seconds of it and she says, "Pack
watch for Turkey Tom. Night rape Tom,
you can't hide and lie."
>> So, does he cry about Trinity here or is
this Is he posting now?
I mean, that was just my question. I
don't know. That's
I'm just wondering, why do you hang out
with Salvo?
>> [laughter]
>> Whatever. And then they all said, "Only
Ethan Ralph could tame this wild
Wow, dude. Dick the Oreo is so soft.
Dude, get nuked and she was actually
ugly Bulgarian MF. Then over on Twitter
Dude, they had to clarify the [__]
the the dick allegations, yeah. All
right, so the Brandon stuff as well. I
don't know what's going to pop in there,
but the Oreo VidCon, Augie RFC
continued. Then going back to Brandon
Buckingham just cuz we already went over
the VidCon stuff.
>> Briefly, Augie tweets out, "Brandon
Buckingham is wing half." And Reva
replies, "Let's do a slightly better job
at having principles." And [laughter]
Augie says, "Erm, how about we go back
to Reddit with this F principal [__] and
enjoy when funny things happen." And
Reva replies, "You aren't Red Bar Kino
Casino." And Augie says, "The funny
thing is, I can just change my mind
whenever I want." And Java replies,
"Yeah, cuz nobody watches you, so no one
cares."
>> When did people start getting offended?
>> Why is Katherine Grey that they call her
so based? Just saying, Clayton.
Three like 80 view tweet telling Augie
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, of course you can change your
mind. Nobody watches you, so no one
cares.
>> [laughter]
>> Review Jack replies Augie's post by
saying, "Did Tom's ex-bitch actually try
to dox the Oreos BBW or [laughter] is it
just that message?" And Augie says,
"According to her Bro, it's like so
obvious. Oh, cuz the one message. I
don't know who who posted one message
and kept spamming it, but I posted a
[__] load of messages explaining it and
then they went and they found one image
or whatever where you can't discern it.
They're like, "Dick the Oreo is claiming
it because of this." Or we all deserve
it.
>> he posted a whole bunch of images and
none of them substantiated it.
He claimed the scholar Australia doxxed
his girlfriend or whatever. And then
none of the images he posted
substantiated it.
And then it's like, "Oh, well, I thought
that if someone didn't believe me, they
would just go to KF and find the post I
meant."
Yeah, it should just page page 376 page
376.
How do I what?
How do I How do I I know. Page 376. Oh,
obviously. Oh, obviously.
Like they intentionally cut all the
context. They're like, "Wow, dude, Nick
DeOreo is so soft."
>> nude and she was actively looking for
information on her. I find it
>> I mean, it was obvious that the people
who are clinging to the doxxing thing
and like calling me a liar were just
pivoting because they were mad that Tom
got out of it.
>> as a by Sacramento about the whole
situation and screenshotting this post
and saying
apparently
>> [laughter]
>> So, it's just not the case at all.
Random Bucky have just went on Twitter
and doxxed her.
And then this guy is out there making
seemingly false doxxing claims. He
presents a bunch of evidence, says this
is my claim, here's the evidence.
And does not include the evidence for
his claim.
What do you meant to assume there other
than he's lying about the evidence?
No, people not going to go to page 376
of the Kiwi Farms thread and find the
post that you're referring to but
haven't directly quoted and haven't
directly screenshot.
That's That's like a absurd ask, Nick,
actually.
It's like an absurd ask. No, he did have
the evidence in the end. He did have the
evidence. She did actually say something
that was pretty clearly responding to
someone asking for her to
um doxx Nick DeOreo's girlfriend or
whatever in in the affirmative. That was
there. That wasn't presented when he was
asked for the evidence.
>> [laughter]
>> It's extreme BPD in a Sacramento saying,
"Yeah, I over blew some [__] Like I
said, I gave into it and told him I
liked it. Should have been more 100
about that, but I will say I didn't lie
about it.
>> this is where it ended. Like this moment
was where it was completely done.
>> Then doing whip ads. Katie brought it up
first, and those texts were real, hence
why he doxxed me. And yeah, a response
is coming at this point. It's all out
there, so whatever, man. Ralph Amale is
ugly as [__] whoever he is.
>> Dude, Ethan Ralph catching a [__]
crazy stray right here. Ethan Ralph a
quote tweets co-
>> [laughter]
>> Bro, there's no way. When he sees this
post by saying
>> This [__] already wants the Ralph
Amale. I woke up to 39 DMs, and they all
said that Ethan Ralph could tame this
wild This [__] already wants the Ralph
Amale. I woke up to 39 DMs. I'm just
curious for all the people out here who
are like super, "Oh my god, it's
doxxing. Oh my god, it's doxxing." Uh
why do you guys hang out with Salvo?
Because I can call out something bad
someone does and still be cool with
them.
It's that simple.
And say my name next time, [__] Say my
name next time, [__] Talking directly
to me.
[__]
[__] ass [__]
I'm in your ass, [__]
I'm deep in your ass. Hanging out like
we're at the [__] bar. Yeah, exactly,
right? It's so crazy, man. But yeah,
that was the point I was making with
Augie on um J Socs the other night. It
was like, you can say
Brandon Buckingham doxxed this guy. A
doxxer's doxxed a girl.
And that's bad.
And you can still be cool with Brandon
Buckingham.
Just like you you know, as long as you
haven't gone out and said
you know, you can't ever associate with
anyone who's ever doxxed.
If you've gone out and set that standard
then yeah, it's a bit absurd, and you
need to reconcile that. You need to
reconcile that. But I don't see that
there's this inherent rule on
association where if you're criticizing
someone, you have to not hang out with
them.
Salvo releasing Nick DeOrio's phone
number
as As I understand it, that's what
happened.
Was bad.
That's obviously bad. We can all we can
all say that's bad to do. Don't release
people's phone numbers.
We can all come around and say that's
bad.
That doesn't mean no one can ever
associate with him again.
You know?
It's the same with Nick. I think some of
Nick's coverage of the Ethan Klein stuff
is totally disgusting. I would still
associate
with Nick, you know, even after
everything.
You know, I don't really have these
super
hard alliance on association online like
that.
As long as people are willing to um
like hear or respond to the criticism.
I'm pretty sure I even mentioned this
stuff to Salvo.
I'm pretty sure we we spoke about it
briefly when I when I called into his
stream.
As long as people are willing to hear
[__]
it's like
you know, people do bad [__]
Criticize them. Don't lie to your
audience. Don't sweep.
I don't see the problem.
And maintain your own standards as well.
Like if you have standards for who other
people can associate with and who they
can't, you should maintain those.
You know, you should maintain those or
reconcile the change.
Yeah, yeah, exactly. So, the you know,
the thing is that Salvo Salvo releasing
Nicholas DeOrio's phone number is
probably bad, but
I just I have no sympathy for
classic.
I mean, that was just my question. I
don't know. That's
I'm just wondering why do you hang out
with Salvo?
It's a very easy response. So, but I
guess to
you know, the the 100 people in Nick's
audience that have actually been there
since Salvo was
was like an enemy, like the ones that
aren't H3 wine moms,
um I guess Salvo's like a big bad name
that they're all really scared of. So,
maybe that maybe that's compelling to a
few of them. Maybe that's compelling to
some of his audience, who knows. And
they all said only Ethan Ralph could
tame this wild [__] Also, whip it. Um
are we in the eighth grade, you silly
[__] CopenSee then also screenshots a
longer response that is Sacramento made
with the caption Sacramento has posted a
short essay response on KF as Ethan and
Leafy dead continue their world record
attempt for victim to walk out any
present speed run. And this is
Sacramento saying, "I understand people
have rightfully called me out for saying
stuff about Tom without providing the
full context and just spinning the
narrative about certain things.
>> Oh, I've got a copy pasting this whole
time.
Thank you.
Sorry, this got moderated out of my
Discord. Let me just um screenshot this.
One moment, guys. One moment. There's
nothing zero happening. It's so boring,
sleepy.
Dude, I'm so uninspired every single day
when I wake up bed emoji and I think,
"Right, what is there to talk about
today?" Thinking emoji, "Well, we love
the ADL. Sorry, David. Guys, don't we
have the ADL? Sorry, David. You're
absolutely correct. Tick. They're
everything 100. Only all of a sudden now
that we against the Tsar of Turkey.
And we want suck Ethan's [__] Eggplant.
The ADL, sorry David, apparently great
and see the ADL, sorry David, [__]
suck, bro. The ADL [__] suck.
The ADL, sorry David, are terrible.
Okay, this idea, light bulb, that Ethan
is a sensible operator.
Man of the year emoji. He's like doing
this based and gigachad. It's not true.
Cross. It's not true. Cross. Ethan's
gone [__] insane. Crazy emoji.
And people aren't [__] talking. Speak
no evil. About it, dude. It's so [__]
annoying. Angry emoji. Dude, people are
acting
mask emojis. But Ethan is this you know
voice. Speaking emoji. Reason. He's the
voice of reason. Speaking emoji. He's
like, you know, "Oh yeah, he's so
correct. Tick." Hello, you got skulls
sent to his [laughter] house.
Oh my god. Banger. Actual banger.
>> [laughter]
>> That's from a That's from Doofoo. That's
a Doofoo post.
The goat. I actually haven't read this
one. to the situation. Here is the full
truth.
>> Oh, [__] Actually, we use that as a
jumping-off point. Because the Oreo
has been lying and misrepresenting
the truth
in his
Hassan coverage again.
So, let's quickly
read listen to not read but reading's
for the transcript. We're going to be
listening to listen to a bit of Nick's
coverage about Hassan's recent ban for
saying Zionist animals.
is biggest I don't have the tweet. It's
not here. That's dude. That's Oh my god,
that's so sad. Holy crap. I literally
had it. Wait. All right. Hassan [__]
got banned. We're going to use Frogan's
face. It's literally just a tweet saying
Hassan Piker's been banned. It doesn't
really matter. It's not a huge deal.
Press the button pro streamer guys.
Hassan [__] got banned and actually
this happened during the last stream. I
said I'd cover it tonight. How does this
coward get away for treating Chud's name
like Voldemort for over a year and then
when he is away he says it on repeat?
Um because
he's lived his entire career being a
complete bitch-made [__] and his
audience don't expect anything
different.
And that's what we're going to do. So, I
was kind of surprised they hit him at
all. Right off the bat, I'm going to
give you my thoughts on this. I don't
really care what he got banned for. I
want to find out together cuz I haven't
even seen the clip. My point, my issue,
the thing that I've always had with
Hassan [__] is that they didn't hold
him to the same standard as everybody
else.
THERE'S A KFC IN YEMEN.
>> Plushy wiggler, Nick.
So, the fact that he's still that he's
still banned right now and it was longer
than a 24-hour ban is a huge shock to
me. Obviously, he went and I believe it
I I don't know this violates Twitch's
TOS. Can you I don't know if you can
just jump another platform and start
streaming but they're not going to
permaban him. So, he can do whatever he
wants. He came to YouTube and had a
wildly successful stream which is the
reason why I never wanted Hassan [__]
permanently banned from anything. People
are like, "Oh, this should be a
permanent ban. Oh, he abused his dog. He
should be banned permanently." So, when
Hassan [__] is permanently banned, he's
going to stay here. It's not going to be
just one YouTube stream where he comes
over and has some fun. He's going to
stay here and he's become a brand risk
on a platform I use. I like him being on
Twitch torching the entire site down but
I don't He said
on YouTube. He literally has a YouTube
channel where he posts videos every day.
There's endless Hasan videos on YouTube.
Dude, what do you mean he's going to
become a brand risk on YouTube?
What the [__] are you talking about?
The funny thing that I never could have
predicted is that Asmongold wants to
start co-streaming to YouTube now as
well, and Hasan [__] has realized how
successful streaming over here actually
is. I wonder if this kills Twitch in the
long term. I wonder if these streamers
realize that their audiences over here,
where their vods are, could actually be
bigger than the audiences they stream to
regularly. And I wonder, maybe if
banning Hasan [__] one time is the is
the little dog that
>> He Dude, Baden Penala releases videos
and streams on YouTube.
Oh, Hasan [__] is going to be a brand
risk. Shut the [__] up, man. that
destroys this entire platform. That
would be very funny. But, ultimately,
yeah, I don't want a brand risk coming
here long term. I do think though
YouTube isn't Twitch, they're corporate,
and their worry is relations. It is the
media. It is I guess my point is he's
not going to be able to sit here and
glaze terrorism. They'll just [__]
ban his entire YouTube channel
permanently, and he'll never get it
back. He doesn't have any like in as far
as I'm aware any connections deep within
YouTube that will protect him. And if he
becomes a brand risk over here, well,
he's got no Dude, the most explicit
terrorism glazing Hasan has ever done
was streamed simultaneously on YouTube.
Is on YouTube in many different forms.
Nobody's received any punishment for
reposting, covering, streaming it. It's
him screaming,
"Yeah, I support the Houthis. 10 toes
down, I support the [__] Houthis."
That's the most explicit terrorism
support he's and it's up. It's up
everywhere. Everyone can see it.
So, what do you mean? friends, they'll
just [__] throw him off the site. I
don't think the CEO is going to come
hang out with him and sing happy
birthday. So, that's a little bit
different than the landscape that he's
used to. I understand why Hasan [__]
streams on Twitch. He gets those special
treatment features. He has a different
standard set for his bounds than
everybody else. He can do more, it's
more lenient. It's the same reason why a
lot of these content creators who were
on Twitch went to Kick because they
could open it up and do a lot more stuff
over there. Hassan has that on Twitch.
There's no incentive for him to leave,
so he talks down to people who go to
alternative platforms. Kind of
hypocritical, whatever. But yeah, long
story short, HassanPiker's banned. Uh,
it's very obvious he was going to come
to YouTube and have an extremely
successful stream. Uh, hopefully this
means that Twitch is setting its path
down to a destruction level where they
have to fire every single person in
their trust and safety team and lay off
their CEO or something or fire their CEO
and and Amazon bring somebody new in.
But otherwise, let's just enjoy the
carnage. So, Frogan
>> He's literally still only Dan Saltman
Cope, bro. How crazy is it Dan Saltman
lost like over a grand's worth of bets
in spicy chat
that Dan that Dan Clancy would be gone
or Twitch would have been sold by
Amazon. He lost those bets
over a year ago. He said January 2025,
over a year ago, he lost all those bets.
25th of January 2025 was the resolution
date for his bets that Dan Clancy would
be gone or Twitch would be sold by
Amazon. We are now a year past the
resolution dates for those bets and
still nothing. Still nothing. All
they've managed to do
is slightly increase censorship of
criticism of Israel.
All they've managed to do is be golems,
shobazgoi.
You know, in Dan's case, not.
But in Nick's case, yes.
Um, for the ADL. That's all they've
achieved.
That's all That's all Nick's achieved.
Got so many comments when she Dude, she
had a thing up here saying Hassan is
banned, I know, because so many people
were hoarding into her stream to let her
know. But none of those people were
donating cuz she only got four super
chatters. Woo. I'm not even kidding you,
that's really funny. So, she's getting
steamrolled to the point where she has
to put text on the screen and they
couldn't even send her a fifth gifted
sub or something or they couldn't even
spare a prime. Now, if you want to spare
a prime for me, you'll pop up right on
the top right there, all right? Uh,
listen, we haven't streamed in months,
all right? We're trying to pass iDubbz
again. He He has outpaced us right now,
but if you want to go subscribe to the
Twitch that we don't use, feel free. We
could beat Frogan together, all right?
Four subscriptions, that's [__] [__]
We could do that this stream. Anyway,
this is the clip that actually got Hasan
banned and I'm watching it right now for
the first time ever. For the first time
with you guys. And pro-Palestinian. This
is another big suck my dick to all the
[__] Israel dick riders out there.
You [__] rabid ultra-Zionist pigs.
You [__] run around going, "Oh my
god, Israel first, Israel first." Why
are you tying this back to Palace?
Because this is precisely the [__]
same [__] Okay? You know what's crazy?
He got hit on the Zionist policy. And I
don't know how I feel about this. On one
hand, I find it hilarious. On the other
hand, I find it hilarious. But I find it
more hilarious because he's the reason
why this policy is made. A bunch of
people use veiled anti-Semitism to
attack Jews. Specifically people he's
friends with and in some cases I would
argue him. I would argue him.
>> [laughter]
>> So that's why this policy
>> So is that why that policy was made?
Is that
Is that why that policy was made?
Because Hasan just couldn't stop himself
always using this as a stand-in for Jew
cuz he's so anti-Semitic. I don't think
Is this a veiled threat to Jews here? I
wouldn't even argue that it is. But the
reason why the Zionism policy
is here to begin with is because people
are attacking Jews with it. That's lit
Hmm.
Cuz they were attacking Jews because of
it what with it. Right, okay. So let's
see, what was the order of events here?
How did this Zionist policy come about?
Well, the first thing I think that's
relevant to see is what happens on in in
late October of 2024 here.
Late October
of 2024. The ADL puts up this thread
saying, "ADL spoke with Twitch staff
today after becoming aware of several
concerning instance on the social media
platform and/or involving Twitch
streamers in the past week.
We appreciate Twitch making the right
decision to finally suspend the streamer
Frogan for abusing our platform and the
Twitch con event to spread
anti-Semitic vitriol during this time of
intense apprehension for the Jewish
community.
Twitch must learn from the situation and
improve how they address anti-Semitism
and hate on their platform, which is an
ongoing and significant challenge.
We encourage Twitch to take meaningful
action, such as collaborating with the
platform's Jewish community, providing
staff, streamers, moderators with
anti-Semitism training, and updating how
they review programming for live events.
We will continue to engage with the
company to help ensure the platform is a
safe, respectful, and inclusive space
for all.
We will also continue to hold them
accountable when they fail in that
responsibility.
Now, a few weeks later,
Twitch published this.
An update on how we enforce our hateful
conduct policy.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah, as part of our hateful conduct
policy, we prohibit the use of terms
that may be may not be harmful or
abusive in isolation, but can be used as
a slur to denigrate others in certain
contexts. In line with that approach,
starting today, using the term Zionist
to attack or demean another individual
or group of people on the basis of their
background or religious belief is
against our rules. We recognize that
Zionist and Zionism also refer to a
political movement. Using the term to
refer to a political movement, whether
in a supportive or critical way, does
not violate our hateful conduct policy.
So, Hassan was doing that.
It's just he referred to them as pigs.
And it was about the political movement.
Whether in a supportive or critical way
does not violate our hateful conduct
policy. Our goal is to not stifle
conversation about or criticism of an
institution or ideology,
but to prevent coded hate directed at
individuals and groups of people.
We include examples of language we
prohibit in our enforcement notes here.
Around that same time,
the same day even, I believe, got this
video called Twitch says Zionist is now
a slur.
Today's topic is Twitch's new update on
hateful conduct policy.
It's official. Twitch has said Zionist,
Zionism as a slur
is no longer allowed, people.
You can't just call anyone a Zionist
anymore. Today's um I have some pretty
conflicted thoughts on this change.
Let me read to you and then I'll give
you my thoughts. Let's see here.
Our hateful conduct policy is designed
to protect our community from attacks
based on a person's
protected characteristics such as race,
nationality, religion, or sexuality.
Policy prohibits harmful behavior
like suggesting that a victim of harm
deserved it
or sharing a hateful image or symbol.
He an image of hate.
I I'm really curious. Hateful image or
symbol, does that include the Houthi
flag that says
um a curse upon the Jews?
Cuz that is still up on his son's
channel, just
for the record, but
maybe then it says Jews. It doesn't say
Zionist. Maybe that's the new
workaround.
Like, yeah, no, [__] it. I said Jews,
not Zionist.
The language used to cause harm and
spread hate changes over time. So true.
To ensure our policies adapt to those
changes, we review them
and how they're applied to prevent those
harms. So admirable.
As part of our hateful conduct policy,
we prohibit the use of terms that may
not be harmful or abusive in isolation
but can be used as a slur or to de-
I'm having trouble with this word.
De-
What? Denigrate? Oh, denigrate.
I thought that's there was like I
thought it was
It almost made me say the N-word.
I'm telling you this denigrate word is
dangerous. So, okay.
Not really that relevant, not really
that important what he's saying in the
video. What's more relevant that we can
show you on the Wayback Machine here
that I finally got to pull up after
fiddling for like last a
Last 2 minutes.
Is um
title this video
where
it's called Twitch updated their hateful
conduct policy because of me.
Was the It's now called Twitch says
Zionist Nazi. Now, back then it was
called Twitch updated their hateful
conduct policy because of me.
I only said
So,
at least 20 vids of Hassans.
I don't think I'm using that word, is
it?
They don't Okay, here's my Here's my
issue. Already Twitch is not enforcing
their own policies.
The Houthi videos of the propaganda
videos of interviewing the terrorist kid
of the Houthis like storming um
the blueprint for the gun used to
assassinate the former Captain Baby
Legs.
>> about any of that, do we? Who Who's
pulling the hairs on that one? We can
have a Twitch sensor being like, "Oh,
pet. No bad impanada. Don't kill Ethan."
>> I'm sure he doesn't mind raving
actually.
>> following the terms of service and his
political model. It's just a slur when
you say it to him. He's saying, "Kill
Jews everywhere." Okay, love that. Very
cool. Um
This one's really good. Check this out.
He says, "Just like Japan, nuclear bomb
is needed to stop Israel." Yeah. Good
idea. This one you guys are going to
like. And I can really see why Hassan
likes it when I read this. "9/11 was an
attack on a legitimate military target.
Those within the towers were the
soldiers of Western financial
imperialism. And it was there that
bureaucratic schemes and carried out
operations to indebt other countries to
steal their resources and bring them to
ruin."
And I mean, Hassan is the the the you
know, be is
Even if Hassan somehow purged the word
Zionist uh from his vocabulary,
which I doubt. Who goes in
the army? So, yeah. Anyway, the point is
Ethan was taking full credit for this.
Ethan was taking full credit and it is
obviously a result of the combined
pressure
of drama YouTubers,
the ADL,
Ethan Klein and Dan Salvato.
That combined pressure is obviously why
that change was made. The ADL had a
meeting a few weeks beforehand were
pressuring Twitch to make wider reforms
to their to to moderation.
Ethan took full credit and was on the
warpath at the time.
And Nick was here sitting there cheering
it all along.
But now,
it's all just it's all just because of a
song.
It's all just because of a song.
from this issue is a [__] monstrous
liar that is Again, dude, Ethan Klein
has literally done nothing in this this
situation. His name is invoked and
minutes later Hassan gets himself banned
from the platform. That is very funny.
Only invest
>> I'm glad that Connor got the longer
clip.
>> in Israel and nothing else. And Paradox
Preacher applies with a screenshot of
Twitch TOS that says, "We prohibit the
use of terms that may not be harmful or
abusive in isolation, but can be used as
a slur or to denigrate others in certain
contexts. Similar to other terms that
may be used as a proxy for protected
group, we treat Zionists as a proxy for
Jews or Israelis if the word is used in
a context to provide harm or violence or
when used to make dehumanizing
comparisons or perpetuate anti-Semitic
stereotypes. Comments regarding Zionism
that are about the political movements,
including criticisms, do not violate our
hateful conduct policy. Comments that
call for violence against Zionism as a
political movements or comments that
would otherwise violate our policies are
not allowed. Allowed example, 'Zionist
settlers keep encroaching Palestine
Everybody knows it now, unfortunately.
Uh it took a charity it took a charity
event failing twice to break the mold.
And Ethan Dude, he's weaponized Iran.
What actually happened is Ethan Klein,
that is triple parentheses. What do you
think about chicanery worrying that
there's like What do you think about
chicanery? All this chicanery. Ethan
orchestrated it. I shouldn't have done
that to you.
Yeah. What was that? I was just guys
still defending this take like a month
later.
Never say that [__] You never hear the
producers. Oh, it's just Okay, it's just
I see him it's about [__] creator
clash stuff. Okay, we don't care about
that. Yeah, that was the point. So, Nick
tried to play like, "Oh, this was just
this was just organic. Hassan just kept
saying so much crazy stuff about about
Jews coded with the word Zionist." And
not that it was actually a specific
pressure campaign that he participated
in alongside the ADL, Ethan Klein, and
Dan Sooman
to try and get Twitch to change the
moderation on the issue of Israel. As if
that isn't exactly what happened.
As if that wasn't exactly what was going
on.
Even though Ethan fully took credit for
it at the time.
But no, it's nothing to do with Ethan,
guys.
It's nothing to do with Ethan. It's
nothing to do with the ADL. And
certainly do not ever imply
that I'm essentially working hand in
hand with the ADL
to achieve these outcomes. Do not ever
imply that that's essentially what's
going on.
So, yeah.
So, yeah. Yep. Yep. Yep.
That's that, guys. That's that. That was
the little thing I wanted to jump off
into.